hey guys welcome back to another episode
of the Woodland podcast there's only two
more episodes left of season three and
what a season it has been as always
thanks for all the support the shares
the messages or just spreading the word
it's been awesome to see where this
podcast has gone and we're so big now
that we've even got Hayden from eqs who
is one of the best registered quantity
servers on the planet he's on board so
if you're looking to build renovate your
existing home or looking at a commercial
development makes you look no further
than the lad Hayden eqs is based in
Palmerston North but they work
throughout New Zealand and they can
provide estimates from concept plans
through to the final design if you're
interested make sure you contact Hayden
and all the information on how to
contact him is in the description below
and also what's a woodland episode
without a few words from the champion
Lair Tim Bateman g'day guys Tim Bateman
here from o studio if you're trying to
get some more control over your own time
and money and therefore looking to open
your own business ostudo might just be
be the option for you
we really are the One Stop Shop for all
things well-being
we're much like a gym really in terms of
a financial model but instead of Fitness
sessions we offer sauna sessions ice
baths flotation therapy massage yoga
Pilates meditation and a recovery space
with tools like normatex look wellbeing
is a 4.1 trillion dollar industry
worldwide and we've found a model that
works so the key for us now is finding
the right people to join the journey if
you are interested fill in your details
at
ostudio.co.nz forward slash LED and I'll
get in touch back to the show
absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when it comes to exciting rugby talents
they do not come much bigger than
today's guests as I'm joined by arguably
the most talented young rugby player in
the game right now he was a Schoolboy
staff or Hamilton boys and he's just off
the back of a special season with the
Tasman Marco and the New Zealand under
20 and now at just 19 years old he's
signed a three-year deal with the
Crusaders and of course like all my
guests are he is an absolute lad he's
one of the greats it is Noah hotham
welcome mate thanks Jabba thanks for
having me mate good to have you on
um do like getting on these young
talented guests at the start of their
career before they blow up and it's
where you're sitting right now yeah
exciting exciting
make better when I do get young guests
on often what happens is they fly
through the start of their career and we
get to when they're about 19 years old
and podcast is over and we're about five
minutes so I want to take it a bit
slower with you I'm Keen to break it
down into smaller segments so
um give me the rundown from your first
five years
so I was
born and bred in Hamilton oh yeah so my
family moved down from Auckland to
Hamilton
um 2003 when I was born
um brought up there
um just across the road from the waikato
river the mighty true minor River where
the waikato draft comes from
um but yeah
um real
grateful for my upbringing I guess I
wouldn't say like we weren't poor we
weren't Rich we're kind of just like in
that middle perfect yeah and met a lot
of
um diverse like hang out with so many
diverse just families that some of my
mates were like a bit well off some
might have been like not well off and it
was just a real good balance to give me
good perspective in life I guess so yeah
started off went to Woodstock primary
school that was my first school
yeah which is just up the road like a
two two minute walk from my house I used
to walk there like every day with my
um siblings Barefoot how many siblings
you got I'm the youngest of five so I
got two older brothers and two older
sisters true and your mum and dad yeah
they're both teachers so my my mom
teaches at school called St Joseph's
which is just the fence between the
primary school that I went to Woodstock
and then there's St Joseph's which is
like the opposite where we like used to
have like little rocks throwing against
each other and whatnot yeah so she
teaches new engines there what's it like
having two parents as teachers
uh good and bad I guess probably more
now once I like look back at it
um more good than bad but back when I
was at school you know I can't really
get away with too much yeah
yeah because he always just like oh do
your best or the standard just like
don't do subjects that are too easy and
too boring making sure that I can't
really skip too much school had to go to
school like every day here and there
um so I just yeah grateful for those
things now but back then I was like
I'll just be like
it's paid off now though because you're
pretty academic okay oh one side too
and what about footy had just started
playing footy before your five
um no no I actually played soccer all
the way up to intermediate I played yeah
I called it soccer I was just muck
around to be honest
um just for my school team
um with a few mates and whatnot and then
because my brother's supposed to play
footy both play rugby and my dad has
coach rugby for a while so that'd all
just take the piss out of me and call me
a [ __ ] So eventually
um played rugby intermediate for Club
Marist up in Hamilton with heaps of my
good mates that are still my mates now
yeah so I started playing rugby at year
seven and when I was younger just played
soccer did swimming
um Athletics and touch yeah pretty much
those what was your favorite you're a
pretty good at tattoo yeah well my
family's kind of just like born and bred
touch pretty much my mom played like rip
touch for some more New Zealand my dad
played Open men's for New Zealand oh
true yeah my older brothers and Open
men's for New Zealand currently yeah oh
well the kind of in like segments like
because they'll have a squad for the
World Cup he wasn't the last World Cup
oh yeah but lost to Australia
um and everyone just kind of played
touch I kind of just grew up playing
touch I guess yeah so that's also kind
of what got me into rugby so how old
were you when you got into ragley I
don't know maybe I'd like to say maybe
10. Oh yeah and when you made that
switch you were like
you were into a day like oh it's kind of
good because I'm like I'm young for my
year group oh yeah so like I was the
people in my year group were playing
say like 12th grade when I was playing
11th grade oh yeah yeah so that kind of
gave me a little bit because I was a
little bit bigger and tubbier than
everyone else sorry were you a tabby cat
yeah when I was a little kid I my
brothers and sisters could still call me
like fat boy do they yeah
no but I used to like it because I used
to like I thought just like being fat
was kind of like fun and like yeah yeah
cute I wanted to be um what do they call
the sumo wrestler oh did you yeah what
when you eat little yeah true just
because I love eating like a lot of food
so what stock do you chasing your real
dream
once you start to get mocked by everyone
once it's not as cute yeah
oh that's right so when you did switch
to rugby by all accounts mate you were
like training the house down from the
age of about 10
um full-on program
ah squatting doing all the all the
training well because my dad when my
family moved from Auckland to Hamilton
he was at Charleston boys high coaching
um and then moved to Hamilton for he's a
deputy principal at Hamilton boys high
and also coaches the first 15 so he was
they're coaching and I'd just be like a
little five-year-old six yard running
around like they'll be doing their boot
camps and in the gym and whatnot and I'd
always just be there pretty much true
yeah and then intermediate because my
intermediate's literally like across the
road from the high school yeah so every
day after intermediate I'd have to wait
for Dad to catch a ride home so just be
and then about first 15 like four years
and go to their boot camps and whatnot
so yeah get a Ivan Cleary Nathan Cleary
Vibe out of there hey just hanging
around the Warriors was old man coaches
it's a little bit like what you were
doing
yeah it was fun though real fun but yeah
and when you did give rugby a go we are
good straight away obviously attached
background would have helped yeah I
didn't at the start I didn't really like
the the contact side of it I guess or
just because touch or just yeah running
touching but were you still a big boy
were you still chubby or yeah yeah not
chubby chubby but like
yeah I was I wasn't like the best but I
was or just average kid I guess what
position did you go
ah started off center fullback did you
yeah 11th 11th grade yeah embarrassed
the big chubby fullback from the back
off the back feet yeah I used to um we
used to play like knee rugby on the
trampoline at my my mate's house I'm
married
um but they're like they went to like
private school and whatnot like one of
my good mates and what about just that
whole different
um spec but they used to call me we used
to like make names on the champ mine was
like the the big Tongan
which is not even done
yeah just yeah yeah did you have some um
good rivalries with your siblings
obviously being the youngest probably
help so yeah yeah for sure especially
yeah Jasmine which is so it goes my
oldest sister 27 then brother 25.
and another brother 23 then Jasmine's 21
or 22 and I'm 19. so oh yeah me and
Jasmine kind of um hung out the most I
guess just because we're close to an age
yeah
um so yeah we have kind of good rival
because she does quite well I guess yeah
and then watching obviously got to watch
both my older brothers play and like
touch Nationals and sevens and whatnot
um for him and boys so yeah what age
could you start beating Jasmine or
you're still not there
um do you remember a year when it's like
finally this year now now
um maybe like high school-ish yeah oh
yeah yeah probably maybe like mid High
school-ish true you just depends what I
don't know yes sir yeah so it's pretty
quick is she faster than you no she used
to be oh yeah ages ago
everyone's still working she's faster
than me but yeah you've got it quite a
high top end
um no I'm not not higher than average
around here but
um
yeah but we used to like have heaps of
fights and whatnot because yeah well
buffer yeah punching yeah one time I got
real Angry um it was like coming into
tax season we went into like the Essex
store and I must have like had like semi
average boots which is like normal but
who ones are like fully broken like
would wear them out until like you can't
wear them anymore yeah because they're
pretty expensive
um and she got these boots and I was out
and I really really want the environment
I just had to pack the biggest salt this
is when I was like at Primary School
yeah so I locked myself in the car
they're like banging them
and then she's in the front and then
we're driving home and she was like
getting cheeky or something and then I
was like just sit in the back and I just
can't remember in the back did you
that's right now but she used to get me
a few too yeah get me in choke holds all
the time oh yeah or the typewriter do
you know what the typewriter is that one
you hold like sit on them hold their
hands down then put your knees on their
hands and then like a type body like
type on their chest and slap them
they didn't do anything
yeah it's a good one if she has a little
sibling yeah good times at the hotham
family yeah he's a young man I didn't
see you as a someone to get in the red
like that and yeah
you're a bit of a psycho angry fella
when I was little I guess that's still
in your way but you just learn to
control it a little bit more yeah yeah
it just got put in my bedroom too much
close the door has anyone pushed yeah
since you've been in like the pro setup
to make you want to crack them or get
close nah not really nanky
nah nah I guess no you kind of just
learn how to how to absorb it and take
the feedback and whatnot yeah the worst
I'd probably get is just like if I was
like venturing with my mates or whatnot
after a few beers yeah or just like
playing video games and just talking
[ __ ] together winding each other right
yeah like one time at school I just
finished this assignment
walking the class site this is at lunch
printed it out at lunch walking
my mate thought it would be funny to
like spit on it
that's the closest I think I've ever got
to like I'd literally come around and I
just stopped and I was like no well
there's good self-control that was that
was the closest I've ever got otherwise
no not really yes yeah much too much of
that yeah okay that's good stuff so when
you let's get back to your footer you
made the first 15 I think at a world
record young age what was it
no you're 12.
yeah and the old man picture
yeah did you get a bit of sticker for
that
all the time I always wondered that yeah
but even like going through year nine
because you go through the age games
under 14 am to 15 days and then just so
yeah oh no way you're dead Victorious
yeah that's right your dad did a video
I'd hated that yeah yeah was there any
truth to it or now we always good enough
oh I'd hope not but
[Laughter]
I hope not so when did you get good like
was it that sort of year 12.
um yeah
I guess I was I was always like all
right like
top middleish not like anything good but
I guess boys just kind of like drop out
throughout the grades that under 14 to
have a team and then guys would just
find other things and like start
drinking with their mates and whatnot
and then there's like a small group of
us that just slowly work away sick and
fifteen and then first and then but I
guess my dad was just really
um
he really just pushed me and my sister
like even on the weekend just like just
little annoying ass things I want you
training or whatnot yeah so we're eating
like something [ __ ] then it's just like
to do in there a little bit things you
just yeah and you just feel guilty yeah
yeah or he'll just take us to the park
and there's yeah he'd always have the
first 15 training and whatnot so it
would always
from pretty young I'd always just be
training with them and Hamilton boys is
like Renault is one of the best best of
Dean schools in the country really isn't
it so
um that program was pretty
pretty professional way for a really
really professional like for some boys
it will make them but for a lot of them
it'll definitely break them
yeah do lots of trainings a week what's
it look like what's a normal week look
like
um is it pretty much professional
probably more than proficient more than
professionally
but more more load I'd say well because
you don't change it in the middle of the
day because you have school so let's say
Monday
it'd wake up we do conditioning which is
and shuttles in the gym like hard as
like you'd be spewing by the end of it
true yeah just because it's it's a big
score there's like 2 000 boys at school
like if you're not going to push
yourself in you'll get in the Colts or
something yeah so there's heaps of
competition
um and like heaps of boys from all over
the country come there
um and then go to school day and whatnot
and then after school we'd have like
um work on like an hour and a half an
hour but just you had to plan like what
you're doing and sides do this stuff
like midis the coach is actually there
because they're
um have teaching stuff usually on a
Monday Tuesday then we'd have jump
session and then uh in the morning so in
these mornings these are both like at
six in the morning before school yeah
before school
um so some boys especially if they live
well away like waking up at five yeah
and then staying until like five in the
afternoon five six
um Tuesday gem session
um let's go would do like big contact in
the afternoon Wednesday no morning
training school and then another session
after school
and then Thursday gym in the morning
let's go and then like Captain John but
almost like GST type Captain Joe after
school then Friday lunchtime would be in
the gym doing a Captain John
and then play Saturday
and then conditioning on Monday did you
see heaps of guys
um in your team who were talented footy
players who sort of packed it in because
it was just too much for them for sure
for sure especially boys like on the
verge like maybe they weren't getting
picked so many weeks but you still have
to do all that training oh yeah so I can
definitely see how like you just put it
on enough just bragged huh yeah yeah and
if you live further away or if like
because you're expected to like get
there however like most boys parents
will take them or whatnot so you do have
to kind of organize and kind of
be self-reliant almost yeah I mean it's
crazy no wonder they're one of the best
schools in the country yeah yeah it's
pretty good setup and in the year 13
that's when you're really sort of
stamped your mark on New Zealand Rugby
massive year for you that year
yeah yeah
um well not really actually reckon oh
yeah it was all right for boys
um but that year 12 I was real gutted
because
I missed out on the I wanted to make
that barbarians I know I didn't oh yeah
I didn't make that and there was some
yeah
um they selected some other boys which
is all good who made it uh I know
[Laughter]
um but I made that
um New Zealand under 18 multi team which
is real cool experience I never
experienced anything like that it's so
like full-on
um in terms of like learning culture and
whatnot and then we ended up beating the
bar bars with this we had a pretty sack
team and then getting like two points or
something away from the NZ schools there
oh true yeah which was real cool was it
you and Taha was Taha in that group
because it wasn't the first 15 with you
right yeah yeah but he's a year it's
weird he's a year younger than me so
when nausea 13 he was year 12. and but
he's older than me true how does that
work uh no clue
yeah but we played yeah we've played
um all throughout there's this thing in
Hamilton called Gwen Shield is
intermediate like under 75 oh yeah did
you ever hear roller mills no it just
sounds good it's like intermediate
tournament under so if I'm going to show
you get picked to Roller Mills like to
play for the waikato team University
like Auckland Ace North Harbor Bay of
Planet just like a young rip thing so we
played all throughout that author
intermediate and high school together
all right so yeah what am I yeah and did
you make New Zealand schools after your
last year yeah yeah 13 made into skills
but that was like covered years
roundabouts so they just selected a
paper team oh yeah
um but yeah and then the pathway to
Tasman how did you get to test oh you
obviously go to otago First don't you
you go down there for uni
um or I was leaving school and I was
like well I don't know like what I'm
gonna do I just wanted to play rugby
um so
I was deciding whether to stay
in like Hamilton with like the waikato
sit up
um and this is when they were just
coming in with that new they were
talking about like ndcs and whatnot
which is what a super contract National
development contract which is like with
the super team is it yeah they bought
those in this year oh yeah yeah but they
were having talks about that back then
so yeah 13 and I was deciding pretty
much whether I stay in Hamilton with
waikato and like
have like some time and with the Chiefs
and waikato
um or
I want to go down to Dunedin because all
my siblings studied in Dunedin oh yeah
my older sister she studied law
um down there and Legion my oldest
brother studied Dentistry he's a dentist
now and my other brother studied physio
down there so he's a physio now true
yeah
yeah pretty much so they all went down
and they loved the day and we went down
there a few times just for the
graduations and whatnot yeah and it was
just it just looked I say and
I kind of want to go down and experience
like life yeah somewhere else meet new
people and whatnot I also wanted to play
rugby and it just ended up that
Highlanders had some connection with
Tasman I think through coaches and
whatnot zotago didn't have a spot for me
they just had an academy spot so I was
like oh
I'd better than that geez a lot better
than that I was just like I don't think
they had something in the future either
which was like yeah I just wanted a bit
of security I guess yeah compared to
like staying at home where I could have
had
something for me
um and then Tasman jumped in with the
Highlanders I think oh yeah I just kind
of weighed that up and I was like if I
stay home I'll probably just regret it
so I ended up leaving to Donna's and
studied
and
me and my other good mate
um the big Dutch man Fabian yeah yeah he
kind of did the same thing came from
Christchurch though
um
so I went into the Halls down there and
then they kind of had it was pretty much
just me and Fabian was like the
Highlanders Academy oh yeah yeah so it
was pretty cool it was so cool actually
yeah real cool so we were kind of like
integrated in and out of things
um and then studied student life like in
the Hall of heaps of new people
um and then halfway through the year
I was on a development contract with
Tasman so I went there went to Tasman
for a bit but they were they were real
good like lenient or like you got units
at like if I wasn't playing or something
if you come back yeah do you study study
do some study and then go back to tazzy
and that go back and forth which is yeah
which is real good and what is the uni
life like these days obviously we've had
guys like Brad Weber who
um spoke very highly of his time at
Dunedin as well like just the ability to
live your life a little bit before you
get stuck into the rugby it's actually
so hissing me like so let's see when
you're there you're probably not
enjoying it as much as when you leave
when you leave you're like oh yeah yeah
um I wasn't like too much amongst it
because obviously rugby so we lived
um hung out with a good group of mates
we would just go here and there you know
um but it was so good just met you kind
of just meet people from like all walks
of life like they like invercargill and
like oamaru and like just random ass
places
I'd never meet you if I didn't go down
to the hall and yeah mingle yeah yeah so
that was pretty bad and how hard was it
to stay focused on the footy down there
obviously you're getting pulled in every
direction
um all your mates are probably on the
purse how hard was it for you to keep
training which obviously did
um it wasn't too bad I guess yeah who
you hang around
um kind of helps that so a lot to my
friends down there were doing footy as
well so
um if we'd have trainings and whatnot
like the under 20 set up that purposely
like put the most training like during o
week oh yeah which is real niggly you
can't even have to like piss up and
front up or you pretty much get dropped
or just don't piss up at all so or just
like pick which Knights you're going out
which one did you do a bit of both
experimentary in there
nah first year I was I was pretty good
like I didn't drink that much yeah and
there
um especially when I had 40 on just left
it because I was like leaving all my
family I was like oh I don't want to go
down to Donna's and then like come back
and um
yeah
so I was like real
um kind of paranoid like I don't want to
leave and yeah um have thrown everything
away because my prince obviously brought
me up like that so I kind of want to
um
yeah just like do my best for everyone
that supported me almost so my first
year I wasn't too bad and then this year
I was kind of like
um let my head down a little bit more
which was real good and how did you find
going up to Tasman
um obviously another new city for you um
New Life
into a professional environment as well
this time so how was that for you it was
my name real good it's either like
really sunny zoo or really raining but
when it's sunny it's easy
um got to go for boys too like there's
heaps of boys I guess that aren't from
there
and then there's a group of them that
are from there so it's like everyone
kind of just
it's not a big like Hamilton or like
Christchurch or something so everyone's
like pretty much forced to if you're not
hanging out with the rugby boys like
there's not many other people
so you're kind of just living with them
everything you do is based around there
yeah the coaches and whatnot the whole
setup was real good ah good words and
um obviously playing wise um you were
young what were you 18 into that
environment yeah yeah Cayman Young on a
development contract so I wasn't sure if
I was even going to stay for the season
or what no I was only in for a few weeks
and then
just ended up um Andrew Goodman was the
coach and he was he's top fella
um just ended up training and I was just
yeah really wanting to have a crack and
he just yeah said I'll keep you around
for a bit so then just stayed there a
bit longer
and just I didn't yeah I didn't play
much I guess the whole first season I'm
just trying trying setting up the
playing team and then
um one of those non-competition games
gave me gave me a crack and then gave me
another kick which is
main especially like just
um since I'm new and I'm not like some
coaches wouldn't do that but I guess
just because yeah trained and I saw that
almost and if I flip that over one thing
I noticed obviously when guys come into
environments when they're 18 years old
they're obviously I'm a little bit
standoffish don't quite feel like
they're ready but you never felt like
that age you always thought you were
ready you felt like you're good enough
pretty much as soon as you arrived there
was definitely heaps of moments where I
was like you probably don't see it but
it was you do kind of get like here and
there and all especially on like big
training days where there's lots of like
rugby based stuff yeah I was pretty
confident in terms of like the whole
setup just from school like around what
you do with your trainings and whatnot
yeah
um and just your routine and how you go
about your way um
um yeah and
um lots of young boys there too which
which helped yeah I I just remember
goody coming back into the room saying
that you'd squared him up about
um giving him a start or giving you an
opportunity and you you don't often hear
that from young kids going into
environments uh telling their coach that
they're ready they often sit back but
I'm just it was awesome to hear that
confidence that you had and then when
you got that opportunity you went out
there and delivered and I think you even
played in the final way like that's yeah
yeah five minutes which is like so so
cool for me especially because the
finals back home it was like well I was
mind-blowing and then seeing all my
family and friends after it was like
yeah full circle moment but it was it
was a big thing that my dad and um the
coaching staff are about life their
parents go crying too
the coaching staff then he's just going
to be like well you're probably still
not going to play it like yeah
um taught lots of the boys in the first
to Dean around like if just there that
South Reliance type thing like if you've
got a problem then you talk face to face
or if you've got any questions talk face
to face without your parents are there
to like support you at home but within
the rugby Circle it's not their job
really I love that yeah so I was yeah
really grateful for it too because uh
when Richard McCool came in to do some q
a he was talking about that with Steve
Hansen and if you're not sure then you'd
like just go up to the coach so I've got
I think I need to work on this this and
this
um do you agree like what else do I need
to do
yeah Matt you're a true Crusader talking
to Richie McCall what a legend oh no I
wasn't talking to her
yeah I love it and then from there you
made New Zealand under 20s
um a year young two-way you've got
another year on it have you yeah yeah so
yeah through the super under 20s yeah
with the Highlanders yeah yeah so
um that's that was real cool initiative
real cool tournament real fun
yeah and then I was lucky enough to get
selected for the NZ under 20s and by
under 20s you've kind of like played
against thieves the boys and played with
heaps of boys so like when you have that
group you already know like 75 of them
um so we had a real cool tour over and
Aussie what did you learn
um because Scotty Hansen was our
assistant coach there but it was he's
real such I know I just like direct and
he's a good balance around being direct
and getting what he wants but also like
supporting you I guess and anyone else
always
um love hearing about other talented
kids anyone else really stand out for
you on that team because obviously yeah
that team was like crazy that's why it's
so exciting playing for those teams
because it's like you give the ball to
anyone and it's like holy he's like
there's a try at the other end
um yeah boys like like Peter Locker
who's crazy yeah
um Wallace a TT like Mecca
um there's so many like the whole team's
just like it's crazy yeah so stacked and
then from there you go back to Tasman
um this year you pretty much you get
your starting spot from the start was it
oh not really like Louis
um Louis Chapman had been there for a
few years Tom bloke he's been there for
a few years and we're a good mate of
mine which has been good like he's
taught me so much and we'll just go back
and forth I guess at the start and got
dropped a few games just for
uh not for anything in particular but
just because Louis was probably a better
a better fit for some games
um but then you just keep grinding away
I guess and yeah scored a lot of tries
oh hey a little bit a little bit some
some tiny ones that I guess most aspects
get just from supporting yeah yeah but
didn't think I was going to get that
many actually yeah how many was it in
the N7 or you're one of the top in the
cup wait yeah I know the boys give you a
hard time about them passing it
um seven I think yeah I think
you've got a big Telly chat you know
exactly yeah yeah
um yeah and especially like when you see
um ex-boys like
um for like Christian like will Jordan
and David havilly and seven or them
because they always put their fan up
after and then once you score a try and
you put your phone up you're like oh
yeah just feel real good at it so then
post that season talk to me about
probably
the biggest decision of your life today
I'm sure every Super Rugby team in the
country was probably chasing you
um how did you get to the Crusaders
um well not every Super Rugby team I
guess there's place for halfbacks yeah
um so I was you had to decide whether to
say in Dunedin or come up here and bring
Hall ended up going to Japan and
Highlanders had Aaron Smith and philau
and still a few younger boys so I kind
of had to weigh up like do I stay
and Dunedin that fifth place ever
um and real good setup or like come here
unfamiliar but chances of playing are
probably a bit higher seeing is I'd be
like oh they pick three halfback squares
down underneath and they have still a
few young boys that are still there um
yeah so I kind of had to make that
decision which is so hard like yeah so
it's always stressful way of making
these decisions you know that sort of
relies on it or you don't really know
how it's all going to play out but
um what was the deciding factor on it
but yeah well that was kind of it it was
like
I was always pretty like I was like oh I
want to start doing like these guys have
pretty much given me everything out of
school like helped me so much made all
my friends down there and whatnot but
then I was kind of yeah thinking around
like Aaron Smith he's top in the world
which is real cool to learn from him and
for Lao and for Lao was still young they
had I don't think they'd name the All
Blacks by then um so that was that was a
big factor and around those two like
flowers probably gonna be there for
quite a bit Yeah and here they had a
spot and like you'd have to say the best
club in the world in terms of success
and track record
um so it was kind of that I was like do
I leave everything and maybe
have a bit of crack here or stay there
and like yeah
so that was pretty much to deciding
factor and how do you see your
competition with obviously Willie Heinz
and Mitch Drummond uh all very different
halfbacks but
um obviously very highly experienced and
you you had something a little bit
different
um I'm real Keen to learn nothing much
yeah as you said like they're way
different uh um like all halfbacks are
different but I definitely have heaps of
wisdom that you can pick off and just a
few kind of yeah take pieces of the pie
of different half-backs and then make
your own pie which is kind of what I
would want to do and yeah other gifts
they have lots of areas that uh my
weaknesses is probably their strengths
which would be good yeah what does your
pie look like
um growing up actually Augustine fully
was my favorite after my favorite player
I am
yeah so I did like a presentation on him
when I was younger did you yeah all
right I don't know yeah he's just oh
he's kind of like a loose Fort yeah yeah
he was yeah yeah just smokes people like
runs it all the time that's yeah
probably not the best parcel kick but
then yeah so here's my favorite and then
obviously I wanted to go down to Dunedin
because I wanted to learn my flower and
Aaron Smith they were like
the best so yeah pieces out of there the
empires I guess what'd you take from
their pie or loving the pie how did you
take by the way Aaron's like passing his
passing is crazy I've never seen anyone
pass that that large even just in
chainings he's just
just the way you like the ball and spent
everything about it it's just crazy how
does he do it what's it what is this
I wish I knew yeah I don't know I guess
it's just pass it on he didn't pass on
the pot oh he did give me little tips
here and there but um just I guess how
much he practices and like the purpose
behind where the practices yeah making
like perfect practice
um and then for Laos just running and
like he's just one of those guys that
like
you put them at
um fall back for the opposition team
yeah he's going to cut you up you put
him at seven he's gonna like Go full on
and like smoke someone and catch you up
he'll like whack the whole team just
stuff like that yeah yeah so he was yeah
he's good mate of mine too like top
fella
um so he was real cool to learn after
and so easy to talk to hey you've been
to a fair few environments you've
learned off a lot of different nines I
think like Finley Crest here and Smith
Louis Chapman now Willie Hines and Mitch
Drummond you've got a lot of um a lot of
people that you've been able to learn
from and you're only what 19 years old
so it's pretty cool though yeah so cool
and even like looking up to courteous or
atema and Xavier because they both went
down when the boys before me oh true so
yeah that was real cool too that was
also kind of another reason why I came
down south rather than staying because
those two had kind of cemented their
spot in in the teams so were they the
two years above you yeah yeah yeah yeah
year 12 Cortez is two years older than
me a I think and then Xavier's two years
older than cool tears yeah mate Hamilton
boys
I'm stacked and how you find living in
Christchurch
that's good eh yeah real good I reckon
it's real Sunny oh yeah yeah right and
you're living with Gianni haveli yes
how's that well he just got back from
Tonga the other day so he's just been
sleeping all the time that's all good
are you did you live with him and Tasman
as well yeah I've lived with them for
the past two years in terms of them oh
yeah and here we rent him yeah yeah sure
he would have learned a fair bit of him
as well I'd imagine yeah but then yeah
those two a lot of My Two Dads almost
what do you like what is your um
everyday living like are you good cook
ah not some I'm a good eater oh yeah not
a good cook who does the cook not bad
cooking though like just like what's
your go to
a chicken chow mein is it yeah yeah you
get those chicken chow mein sachets
no like the flavor session yeah yeah
like pre-made oh yeah and then just stir
fry veggies you know that's pretty
simple and you can make heaps for the
next lunches nice
um I'm pretty clean though like low-key
have OCD like around being clean tidy
house
or not really the house so much more
stuff my spaces oh yeah yeah
so you won't go clean the kitchen oh
sometimes like when I was down and
downers with Cam and Fabian at my flat
in Dunedin I was pretty OCD and I just
get annoyed ass
[Laughter]
okay well we did get heaps of questions
from you lots of your friends actually
and siblings I think uh first question
who's your training crush or who do you
admire at training uh down in dunners
I like to watch obviously flown Aaron
Smith here yeah
um
Ethan Blackadder oh yeah yeah it's a
capital good correct training yeah okay
next one was there any pressure on you
by your father or sister coming through
you've kind of mentioned that yeah yeah
if I didn't know if I didn't um go good
then they'd just roast me to [ __ ]
laughs
okay next one what's it like having Taha
follow you everywhere
so he's one of my classmates is real
good but we're pretty similar in terms
of just everything I guess uh he's
classed away yeah top yeah he's he's
pretty skillful like we've played touch
and sevens and rugby all together which
has been made and you speak about tax
you're Keen to play
um New Zealand touch at some point
aren't you for sure for sure I played
under 16s and under 18s I was the
captain of that under 18 side boy we got
smoke Aussie a good guy I'm so good
crazy
um
yeah
that's what like one of my goals to go
to a World Cup and try one and World Cup
and touch yeah
rugby and Winter Olympics
Sevens or wrestling
yeah that's kind of my ultimate goal
which is like quite outrageous but I
guess you kind of have to have it
outrageous goals mate if anyone's gonna
do it it's you yes so when would this
when would you look to do the transition
to sevens and then touch obviously touch
is no Financial benefit
to go there
so yeah so you'll probably be back into
your career you'll be turning probably
down like a million dollars too when
some people take a sabbatical to go to
Japan
is that what you do is that what you do
to achieve that goal uh maybe like when
I was all through high school I was like
I want to make touch a professional
sport life it's a professional sport
that's what I'm going to do sure yeah
um there's so many people that I feel
like that like Mitch hunt
um
yeah
Shawn Johnson Caitlin Palmer Ryan
papenhausen right yeah there's so many
people that start off playing touch it's
just oh it's such a good game eh yeah so
good and just like the skills that
relates to touch What stopped it going
professional maybe if you make enough
calling in your career you can start it
for like has it been anyone smart enough
or I guess hasn't been enough
fan base around it yeah but hopefully
create that yeah like when you're a big
gun Super Rugby all black a limb type
winner if you transition to touch could
become proficient yeah hopefully
hopefully right yeah good love that one
okay next question are you scared of
your father-in-law Jamie Joseph
is he your father-in-law no my
father-in-law now he's my girlfriend's
Dad yeah
oh yeah
when you're married yeah oh yeah yeah oh
yeah but no he's the top father when I
first made it I was like oh my god when
I because when I first went out with my
girlfriend
um Maya I was I didn't know I didn't
know that was her dad because I met her
through touch we went to
um on New Zealand touch tours together
and then like saw each other at
Nationals and um whatnot so we met
through there and then everyone like
once we started um going out
everyone was like aren't you scared of
his dad I said dad I hadn't changed out
as Jamie Jackson I was like oh I don't
want to make them
and but they met him and he's such a
nice fella has he squared your ass at
all no no no he's too nice for that area
unless I did something stupid you know
you wouldn't do that but um has he gave
it does he give you like advice as a
coach to a player or now stays away from
it yeah not really I guess when we talk
it's yeah it's not really about rugby I
guess but he's like
he's one of the top Cooks I think I've
ever met true like ridiculous better
than your chow mein
probably just
oh true
because he's obviously in Japan in the
cuisine they have over there yeah yeah
true that's interesting crack up okay
next one this one's a good one drop the
quad routine you do have massive quads
we've had bodies given the speed program
um Sam Kang gave the neck program if we
get you a chord program we can create
almost a perfect athlete you need
someone with bigger quads like so you
don't need to do that right you've got
massive quads for a nine
um
um single leg squats I think this is
okay yeah true when I first went to
tazzy
um I was doing these like and you're
like lowered down on a single leg like
um
isometrics yeah but it was just for my
patellas
your quads are big enough like why are
you thinking about that what I was like
confused there because I like I didn't
really know
um Alex Naperville too much yeah I was
like oh these are for my patellas that I
get real super tellers yeah so maybe
that that's the secret how it's worked
whatever it is okay
um tips on growing a mow oh uh I don't
know my brother just
this is just new James
my brother grew on down to Donna's and
it was just like
oh it was just like a fat slug and I was
like oh
cut it please yeah and then my other
brother grew on and I was like oh what
are you doing and then
yeah my dad used to have one who knew he
was playing touches they have a fat
Mallet yeah and then I don't know that's
just the only place social grows on mate
looks good it's getting thicker and
darker by the by the mouth I'm just
scared to shave it and like I have a big
tan line underneath oh yeah true big
pasty
okay next one ask him about his X Factor
audition X Factor this is from the big
Don Almighty
uh that's not faster
now he tries to refer me to
um this this dude called Cody Lee how
have you seen it I haven't if you
haven't seen it look alike is he does he
look alike first I think it's because uh
yeah singing but he's the audition on
YouTube Cody Lee sure I'll look at that
okay next one another one from the great
lad Noah Foster does he purposely try
and look like Sid the sloth from Ice Age
uh I'm gonna have to smash them
it is a little bit
so they start okay I've been called um
the dude off have you watched Flushed
Away before oh yeah I am yeah what is it
little rats um his names Roddy oh Roddy
yeah you're gonna say already too yeah
yeah did you get that one much
[Laughter]
okay next one oh Max X is here
um what was your first car
the guy that uh that I drove here my
Ferrari yeah
yeah I call it the Ferrari what is it
it's uh
it's a little [ __ ] box to me yeah
just as literary and it's called Leticia
actually
um Arena do you know what A Renault is
yeah yeah like one of those French cars
yeah it goes pretty good oh not really
yeah but just getting out of the
driveway Rivers
I like it okay next one okay Miller ask
him about his performance on the Bears
and the Gold Coast after new tournament
um
after our NZ 20s we we just had a couple
of beers
um went to the pub yeah
um and then there was just like the
Aussie boys within Argentina boys
Argentina was so funny that's so funny
yeah and then um just yeah everyone was
just shouting beers and whatnot and then
just smashed a few too many drinks beers
rtds and like straights and whatnot and
it was just yeah I was all good in the
club and then walked out of the club was
like oh I need some fresh air just like
chill jelly Vibes walked outside and I'm
just sitting at this bush like just
chilling with the boys in their neck
when I was just like turned over them
and then I don't remember anything after
that
yeah I just remember waking up on my
um
because we're in like in the rooms up in
the hotel in like the 10th floor and
whatnot I just remember waking up on on
the floor on the kitchen just like
spewing all over me
if I used to just like pushed me or I'm
like get up get up I'm about to hey he
said this one thing is I'm gonna call
the manager I don't think it will and
then as soon as I heard that I was like
I'm good
was it after you won it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's nice okay next one
this one's from speaking of big Fabian
ask him about the best memories from 12C
Regent Road and his Ventures on Castle
Street uh that was our flat down in
Dunedin that was me CAM and Fabian yeah
it was a real good time
um it was just us two flags together and
it was on Queen Street which is like
where most of the third years go but I
just wanted to be kind of away from but
away from Castle but close enough to
walk so it was like a couple hundred
meters down the road said heaps of Good
Times drowning down there
um yeah having a few good nights with
them but my flat yeah taking the piss
out of each other nice yeah I like it
okay what do you want to do after the
footy
oh
heaps of things I guess
um I kind of like taking photos I've got
a few film cameras yeah which is I've
never seen you take a photo oh exactly
how secret about it oh yeah no I'm just
low-key yeah um but film's pretty
expensive like you have to pay 20 bucks
for a canister film and then get it
developed and whatnot so I'm gonna
invest in a digital camera 20 bucks Matt
you're right yeah but you're a full-time
Crusader you don't get unlimited photos
you get like 20 photos oh okay so that's
40 bucks each time you take 20 photos
and then it just ends up you know yeah
and uh yeah
um I kind of like business stuff but all
right that kind of interests me like um
ice um Isaac John what he does and
whatnot all that type of stuff I really
enjoy
um make touch professional
yeah that's cool because you um you've
been studying marketing eh yeah
um applied science which is just
physical education but a minor in
marketing oh yeah yeah yeah yeah but I
don't really know I guess there's heaps
of stuff that I can't do after rugby but
still still a few few more years away
and that goes on to this next one how do
you want to look back on your career in
15 years oh
um
I guess
not regretting anything like just
doing my absolute almost best like
leaving no stone unturned
um not wishing like I'd gone longer or
trained more or whatnot which is a good
thing that my dad probably installed to
me I was watching NCM like I always
let's go through reels in the scene that
Michael Jordan said it was like your
competition's not against
um other people you're versing but
against your capabilities
like that like that yes sir and my
sister got me the thing which is my only
competition is who I was yesterday wow
yeah so just trying to be the best me I
guess
um on the field and off the field
yeah so trying to see how far I can
climb up the mountain small steps at a
time mate exciting stuff though okay
last question ask everyone this and
might be a little bit to do about that
because that was good advice but um
what's the best piece of advice you have
for a waddle ad listener
oh best piece of advice
one would be
[Music]
um
ask questions I guess like when I was
leaving school and I didn't know what I
wanted to do and I was just like
who's someone that's played rugby gone
to UNI or like done something along
those lines that I wanted to do
so my brother was good mates at
duplicate oh yeah
oh I think so but anyway I was just like
oh he's a good mates that surely I'll
just message him and he'll just tell me
so that was that was real cool oh you
missed yourself yeah I just messaged him
on Instagram like not thinking about it
I was like oh like do you have any
advice at a school and he just sent me
like all this stuff like yeah just like
pick what you wanted I'd went to UNI I
did all this stuff I think which is like
really cool that is a professional rugby
player just like the year 13 at school
um so what a lamb yeah top of that
um I guess the worst thing you can um
someone can say to you is like no go
away yeah anyways I just ask right there
and you've got another one jeez another
one a good one yeah that was good
um don't wash your linen clothes with um
other clothes
like with the washing machine yeah it's
good advice yeah what happens
just runs your clothes at your Landing
clothes that's it yeah
all right yeah just make sure you know
how to do your washing properly because
that's a
I can readily ruin your closet I didn't
even know that
it's probably you don't do your washing
Sandy yeah that's probably like I've had
a lot of advice but that's probably the
first time I've genuinely learned
something thanks yeah that's why I took
it took a while to think now I just need
your chicken chow mein recipe and I'm
away
yeah yeah
oh good oh yeah good what a very good
podcast
um
absolute honor getting you on um no it's
been a pleasure working with you over
the last couple years excited for what's
ahead for you especially this year but
not just this year in the future and
seeing you pay for the All Blacks and
make touch professional and go to the
Olympics that's going to be there's
plenty to follow so um yeah really
looking forward to following see what's
ahead for you and appreciate you coming
on water land cheers Jimmy appreciate it
it's been fun you're a lad
[Music]
absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]